>>> ALL RISE FOR THE MIDTERMS!
I'M MICHAEL SMERCONISH IN
PHILADELPHIA.
HISTORICALLY, VOTER TURNOUT FOR
MIDTERM ELECTIONS IS A BIG
DROP-OFF FROM PRESIDENTIAL
YEARS.
USUALLY, THE MORE MOTIVATED
VOTERS ARE THOSE FROM THE PARTY
NOT OCCUPYING THE WHITE HOUSE.
IN MIDTERMS, SINCE GEORGE W.
BUSH SECOND TERM THE PARTY OF
THE INCUMBENT PRESIDENT HAS LOST
AN AVERAGE OF MORE THAN 40 SEATS
IN THE SENATE AND HOUSE
COMBINED.
AND ALL OF THE REPUBLICANS NEED
IS A HANDFUL OF CONGRESSIONAL
SEATS AND ONE SENATOR TO PUT
KEVIN McCARTHY AND MITCH
McCONNELL BACK IN CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE AND SENATE RESPECTIVELY.
THE INEST.
>>> THE RELEASE OF ANY FINAL
REPORT WOULD COINCIDE WITH THE
BEGINNING OF MIDTERM CAMPAIGN
SEASON.
THERE REMAINS, HOWEVER, ANOTHER
MIDTERM INTANGIBLE THAT CANNOT
BE AVOIDABLE BY EITHER PARTY.
TWO CASES WILL BE HEARD THIS
FALL BY THE SUPREME COURT WHICH
HAS BEEN RESHAPED BY THREE TRUMP
NOMINATED JUSTICES.
RULINGS WILL COME ON TWO OF THE
MOST HOTLY CONTESTED ISSUES IN
AMERICAN POLITICS.
ABORTION AND GUN RIGHTS.
HERE IS A BRIEF PRIMER.
THE ABORTION CASES SEEKS TO
OVERTURN A FIFTH CIRCUIT COURT
BLOCK OF A MISSISSIPPI STATE LAW
ENACTED IN 2018 WHICH BANNED
ABORTIONS AFTER 15 WEEKS.
THE ROE VERSUS WADE PRECEDENT
PROTECTS BETWEEN 23 AND 24 WEEKS
FOR A FETUS.
THE MISSISSIPPI CASE WOULD
REDUCE THAT TIME LINE BY ABOUT
TWO MONTHS.
NOT TO BE OUTDONE THIS WEEK
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
SIGNED A LAW THAT WOULD BAN
ABORTION AFTER SIX WEEKS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS MAP.
IT SHOWS THE RESULTS OF A "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" ANALYSIS AS TO
WHERE ABORTION RIGHTS WOULD BE
RESTRICTED IF ROE WERE TO BE
OVERTURNED.
THEN THERE IS THE GUN CASE.
HERE ARE THE PRECEDENT AT ISSUE
IS JUSTICE SCALIA'S 2008 OPINION
IN D.C. VERSUS HELLOR THAT
CITIZENS HAVE THE RIGHTS TO GUN
OWNERSHIP AT HOME.
LOWER COURTS SAY THE RIGHTS ARE
NOT UNLIMITED TO ALLOW FOR SOME
REGULATIONS.
NOW THE COURT WILL RULE ON A NEW
YORK LAW CHALLENGED IN THE CASE.
NEW YORK STATE RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION VERSUS -- A NEED TO
CARRY A CONCEALED HANDGUN
OUTSIDE THE HOME.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE COURT IS
BEING ASKED TO SAY THE CONCEALED
CARRY IS A PART OF THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
THE SUPREME COURT TAKES THE
SUMMER OFF.
THESE TWO CASES WILL BE ARGUED
IN THE FALL AND DECISIONS WILL
COME IN THE SPRING OR EARLY
SUMMER OF 2022.
SHOULD THE COURT ADOPT
CONSERVATIVE POSITIONS?
THAT MIGHT REMIND REPUBLICAN
BASE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF WHITE
HOUSE CONTROL AND SPUR A GOP
TURNOUT WHICH RETAKES THE HOUSE
AND SENATE.
OR IT COULD MOTIVATE WOMEN AND
THE YOUNG WHICH WOULD ENCOURAGE
DEMOCRATS.
THERE IS ONE MORE CONSIDERATION.
IVE RULINGS ON ABORTION AND GUNS
MIGHT CONVINCE THE REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS TO SHED ANY
RELUCTANT THEY HAVE ABOUT
EXPANDING THE SIZE OF THE
SUPREME COURT SO AS TO ENCOUNTER
THE IMBALANCE WILL LIKELY
CONTINUE BEYOND THE BIDEN YEARS.
THE PRESIDENT CREATED A
COMMISSION TO STUDY POTENTIAL
CHANGES TO THE COURT IN APRIL.
THAT COMMISSION MET FOR THE
FIRST TIME JUST THIS WEEK.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO DELIVER A
REPORT TO THE PRESIDENT IN ABOUT
SIX MONTHS.
OR JUST ABOUT WHEN THE ABORTION
AND GUN CASES WILL HAVE BEEN
ARGUED.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK.
GO TO SMERCONISH.COM AND ANSWER
THIS SURVEY QUESTION.
WILL SUPREME COURT DECISIONS IN
2022 HELP REPUBLICANS,
DEMOCRATS, OR NEITHER.
JOINING ME NOW, IS "THE LEAD"
AND "STATE OF THE UNION" BEST
SELLING AUTHOR IS JAKE TAPPER.
HI NEW NOVEL "THE DWELL MAY
DANCE."
CONTINUES TO FOLLOW HIS FIRST
NOVEL.
CHARLIE GOES TO HOLLYWOOD IN THE
EARLY 1960s.
I LOVE THE BOOK AND ASK YOU
ABOUT IT IN A MOMENT, JAKE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF MY THOUGHT
SUPREME COURT TO PUT ITS
THUMBPRINT ON THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS?
>> I THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON.
EVERYTHING YOU SAID.
I WOULD SAY THERE IS ALSO AN
ARGUMENT THAT IT WILL HELP
REPUBLICANS IN SOME STATES AND
HELP DEMOCRATS IN OTHER STATES.
THE IDEA THAT THESE CASES,
ESPECIALLY I HAVE TO SAY,
ESPECIALLY I THINK THE ABORTION
CASE.
THERE REALLY DOES SEEM TO BE A
MAJORITY ON THE COURT, AT THE
VERY LEAST THE FACT THEY ARE
TAKING UP THE CASE SUGGESTS
THERE ARE FIVE JUSTICES WILLING
TO RECONSIDER THE PRECEDENT SET
BY ROE V WADE.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR FIVE
JUSTICES ARE READY TO DO THAT
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE THAT THIS
WILL BE GOOD TO MOTIVATE
DEMOCRATS IN, FOR EXAMPLE,
VIRGINIA, TO GET THE WOMEN AND
YOUNG VOTERS AND PROGRESSIVES
OUT TO VOTE IN VIRGINIA.
AND IN OTHER PLACES, IT MIGHT BE
GOOD FOR REPUBLICANS.
IT DOES REAFFIRM, FOR EXAMPLE,
THIS IS PROBABLY THE LONGEST
LASTING LEGACY OF THE TRUMP
YEARS FOR GOOD IN THE EYES OF
CONSERVATIVES.
THE IDEA HE GOT THESE THREE
JUSTICES ON COURT AND ROBERTS IS
A SWING JUSTICE, IT'S A 5-4
COURT IF YOU PUT ROBERTS WITH
THE LIBERALS SO IT'S REALLY A
6-3 COURT SO THAT WILL REAFFIRM
TO CONSERVATIVES WE NEED TO KEEP
FIGHTING FOR THIS, WE ARE
WINNING.
>> ONE WONDERS IF THESE EVENTS
COULD OVERTURN THE, I THINK,
TRADITIONAL PATH WHICH HAS BEEN
THAT REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVES MUCH MORE CONSIDER
THIS ISSUE WHEN THEY VOTE FOR
PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED STATES
THAN DO DEMOCRATS AND
PROGRESSIVES.
>> EXACTLY.
I MEAN, THIS HAS BEEN MORE OF A
MOTIVATING FORCE FOR
CONSERVATIVES, FOR REPUBLICANS
IN THE PAST.
BUT, RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN SO
SINGULARLY FOCUSED ON THE
SUPREME COURT AND THE JUDICIAL
NOMINEES.
REMEMBER, THIS IS WHY MITCH
McCONNELL AND OTHERS WENT ALONG
WITH TRUMP FOR SO LONG BECAUSE
HE LET THEM DO WHAT THEY WANTED
TO DO WITH JUDGES.
I THINK IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE
THAT THIS WILL HAVE THE EFFECT
OF MOTIVATING WOMEN, MOTIVATING
YOUNG PEOPLE, MOTIVATING
PROGRESSIVES BECAUSE IT'S TRUE
THAT ABORTION RIGHTS REALLY DO
CHANGE IN THE BALANCE.
IT'S NOT CHICKEN LITTLE, THE SKY
IS FALLING.
IT REALLY COULD HAPPEN.
LOOK.
I'M NOT SUPREME COURT ANALYST,
BUT IT LOOKS TO ME WHAT I'VE
READ OF THESE JUSTICES THERE ARE
FIVE PHOTOS TO CONFIRM THE
MISSISSIPPI LAW.
IF THAT LAW IS AFFIRMED AS
CONSTITUTIONAL, THE BAN ON
ABORTION AFTER 15 WEEKS WITH
PUNISHMENTS FOR PHYSICIANS IF
THEY VIOLATE IT, WHAT IS TO SAY
THAT GREG ABBOTT'S LAW IN TEXAS
THAT YOU REFER TO, WHICH
ESSENTIALLY BANS ABORTION.
THEY SAY THEY BAN IT AFTER SIX
WEEKS.
BUT A LOT OF WOMEN DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY ARE PREGNANT BEFORE
SIX WEEKS INTO A PREGNANCY.
IT ESSENTIALLY BANS ABORTION.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
DOES A RULING